iniciamos con el tenista serbio novak
djokovic porque él ofreció una
entrevista después de lo vivido en
australia y que dijo dijo entre otras
cosas que está dispuesto a sacrificar
algunos torneos si lo obligan a
vacunarse esta entrevista fue ofrecida
al medio británico deep is your land
durante la conversación expresó que no
está en contra de las vacunas pero sí
afirmó lo que ya habíamos manifestado
anteriormente a sacrificar su presencia
en algunos torneos y es obligado a
vacunarse djokovic se ha mostrado en
favor de la libertad de elegir lo que un
individuo debe poner en su cuerpo el
tenista no pudo participar en la pasada
edición del abierto de australia debido
a que a juicio del gobierno australiano
no cumplió con las medidas sanitarias
impuestas para ingresar al país esta fue
la primera entrevista que el número uno
del mundo ofrece luego de la situación
vivida en medio